oh my goodness I'm so nervous this is my
first video hi guys I'm Eriksson Josh
you probably don't recognize me but you
have seen my work I've been editing for
new rocks for quite a while now so that
means whenever you've seen an
out-of-place transition or a character's
name misspelled or even the incorrect
title of a youtube video yeah that was
me
Pino everyone makes mistakes and after
all there's no places more forgiving of
mistakes than the internet and speaking
of mistakes wow what a year 2016 has
been I mean great we had some amazing
things happen this year but we've also
had some of the biggest and devastating
disappointments of all time so instead
of your retrospect of the year and all
its positives I thought it might be more
in 2016 fashion if we had a big top-5
the things that we got wrong let's just
jump right into it shall we
starting with number 5 but you had told
me in 2015 the following year we were
gonna get not one but two of the biggest
head-to-head movie mashups of all time I
would've told you duh I read the news
but I also have been just as optimistic
as Phillip was beginning of this year I
think just expect this thing to dominate
the cultural conversation for a long
time and deservedly and Philip kind of
was right Batman V Superman did dominate
majority of the conversation but I don't
think in the way that we may have
intended and look despite what your own
feeling the movie might have been
critically it was well to put it lightly
not well received in fact it currently
holds one of the lowest rotten tomato
ratings of any superhero movie ever it's
lower than daredevil hello darkness my
old friend
at least the studio did redeem itself
when they finally release to a side
squad later that year
Oh what no connected like that either
huh there's nobody sitting here number
four it's being obscure hero magics
Captain America Civil War is probably
the most anticipated Marvel movie of all
time I mean not only were you getting
what was essentially Avengers 2.5 but
you were also getting a movie covering
one of the biggest story arcs in the
Marvel comic universe a storyline that
ends with the death of a very major
character so it was not ridiculous for
us to believe that most likely someone's
going to die in this film now all signs
pointed that being Bucky since we've
seen him in this same fight scene in the
other trailer but here's the bigger
question is he dead like he looks kind
of dead he could totally be dead and yet
the accepted a roadie getting paralyzed
and then well not so paralyzed and Bucky
losing his replaceable vibranium arm
things were pretty status quo by in this
movie I mean yeah sure did Prince the
Chavez father still dead and so are most
members of the United Nations that were
in a blast radius but with the exception
of like a black guy and a calm when you
feel better letter Tony and Steve Rogers
let things pretty copacetic and honestly
I feel strongly that their radio songs
will not last long as soon as Stannis
completes the 18 movie circuitous plant
he has to get those Infinity stones
number three I don't have to hold these
fingers up now if you have a scene
Westworld what have you been doing with
your TV time I know Walking Dead
everyone's watching Walking Dead but as
a show to take over the off season of
Game of Thrones I don't think any TV
show made quite as big a splash as
westphall I don't want to ruin it for
you but one of the biggest reveals
happened the first five minutes of the
pilot episode and was something that
almost none of us could have ever
predicted and Harris's character the man
in black this man in black is an
immortal host with kind of a cloudy
morality probing the outskirts of West
world in search of a maze to access the
parks inner sanctum may see in the
original West world movie that this show
is based off though Yul Brynner plays a
outlaw cowboy robot that goes absolutely
haywire and starts killing every
one of the guests and he's remembered by
his iconic outfit which is in all black
so really when fans saw that preview for
the West world TV series it made sense
that Ed Harris being an all black meant
that he was going to play the gunslinger
and while he does go on a rampage it
wasn't as a haywire robot but as a human
guest lived in visiting the park for a
very long time and is looking for
something way deeper than just playing
cowboys and Indians that's all I'm gonna
say
honestly if you haven't watch to show
you it you have to get up-to-date
although granite you have quite a while
because it's going to be another two
years before the second season comes out
number two now this was a season to
remember not only do we get the
long-awaited battle the bastards hand
Circe's violent vengeance on all of her
enemies but also this was the first
season that the show had finally outrun
the books that the show is based on you
think both fans and newcomers alike
completely in the dark and speaking of
being in the dark despite most of our
predictions being spot-on Jon's lineage
to Targaryen bran being involved in the
hood r's backstory Rickon being nothing
more than a shaggy dog and of course
Cersei using wildfire to make a crater
in Westeros there was one particular
theory we actually couldn't even really
decide on how things were going to end
between Arya and a house of black and
white there were literally so many
possibilities we had to go into really
out there theory time what if this is
all part of artists plan maybe jock ins
planned and it could even be him who's
pretending to be arya in this moment and
those clothes they are definitely a very
different outfit than we last saw her
and in fact she walks by someone dressed
exactly like arya was recently dressed
could that be the real Arya was Syrio
Forel involved no of course not he's
dead you should get over it there was
even a theory that extra was involved
simply because he wore a blue outfit
that made him stand out from the rest of
the crowd but it turned out no one was
right unless of course you guessed the
obvious which was it originally had much
of a plan and she actually did this let
somebody who was dressed in an old
woman's mask that she could have
recognized from episodes earlier walked
right up to her and stabbed her multiple
times in the stomach causing her to
nearly bleed to death and have to find
help me be one person she was supposed
to originally kill leading that
to their death and eventually leading
that set assassin into a dark room jesso
she could finally use her blind fighting
skills in a literal face-off I do think
she must've had some of this plant
obviously we do see her earlier in the
stone room blowing out a candle but I
find a hard to believe that's suffering
multiple stab wounds and having the one
person she refused to killed actually
end up dead was at all part of her plan
number one
okay so obvious is old news that the
trailers really mislead us by having
pretty much like 50% of the footage not
actually in the movie and that's a real
aggravation for me because I was
incredibly excited to see how a face-off
between gin and a Thai fighter would pan
out but when it comes to theories about
ro1 story nothing takes a cake quite
like Jin's possible relation to Rey in
the force awakens I think there's a way
she could be raised mom definitely a way
she's ready to well lurk she isn't by
Jin joining a long line of pasty white
brunette females a kick-ass in the Star
Wars universe not one moment in row one
suggests that she might be in any way
related to Ray and considering how
things end up for her in the movie I
don't think we're gonna find out that
she is unless of course it's revealed
that moment before Jin got picked up by
stormtroopers she was leaving her only
child at the doorstep of an imperial
fire station and an episode ADA 2
revealed that Ray's last memory of her
mother was of her dangling Kyber crystal
necklace hanging in front of her face
but I'm gonna make my own 2017
prediction and say probably not so of
course you liked this video please
subscribe to our channel and make sure
to hit the bell icon so you get notified
whenever our new videos come out and if
you really want to be part of our team
consider pledging to our patreon from
every one of the new rock stars team we
are sincerely grateful to all of our
2016 patrons without you guys I wouldn't
have a job but also we would not be able
to make nearly as many videos as we did
this year and we love doing this for you
and if you want to tweet at me about any
theories I might have not mentioned or
anything in 2016 that just upset you in
general you can find me at Jess Erickson
and of course you wonder where our
videos come out or participate in
discussions about what videos we should
do next follow us at new rock stars
thanks again for watching I guess I'll
see you guys all next year in 2017
you
[Music]
[Music]